today's question comes from noah
in north carolina here's what he asks he
says i'm married with a one-year-old son
i made a promise to myself when i was
young that i would always be present for
my child in his life
since my father was absent from mine i'm
caught between honoring the promise i
made myself and working my second job as
much as possible to pay down my family's
debt
i feel like i should work as much as
possible now so i can be present later
when my son knows whether i'm there or
not but i'm also caught up in knowing
that i may miss important milestones in
his life we have 67 000
in debt two cars and my wife's student
loan how would you handle this
you know it's interesting because i
think this is one of those things where
and i see this a lot regardless of if
you're a man or woman or stage of life
or type of debt
it's so easy to focus on where you're
not if you're working that second job
you're trying to pay off your debt
you're thinking about your son am i
there is he okay is he walking did he do
something new
and you're not able to be present but i
think one of the things that's so cool
about this question from noah is he has
a goal
he has focus he wants to get out of debt
he wants to
get his family debt-free and
and he's going to do that doesn't mean
that you're not going to be present for
your son's life
but will you see every time he giggles
and laughs no
you won't but it's because you're able
to
work the second job to reach your goal
so i think if one of the things that i
would encourage
noah to do is to be where your feet are
so be present wherever you are when
you're at work bust it knowing that it's
not going to be forever you have to work
a second job
but also when you're home with your son
be present with your son be proud of the
moments that you
are with him and really give yourself
grace for being in this season of trying
to get out of debt without feeling like
it has to be all one or all the other
give yourself a little bit a little bit
of permission
in this season dave what would you say
because i know it's a it's a financial
question but it's also kind of a
uh it has an emotional pull to it
because of his history there with his
dad
yeah sell your stupid cars
get two car payments you wanna get out
of debt faster
get rid of your cars uh turn your
television off when you're at home
and there's no reason to leave it on
when you're not at home so just turn
your television on
so i mean people talk about how how
nurturing they are to their children and
they're sitting and watching freaking
hbo while the kid's riding
right riding around on his knees and
hands and knees on the carpet i mean
you're not any more there than if you
were there if you weren't there
so turn television off sell the two cars
that's first things i would think about
there
listen if you'll live like no one else
later you can live like no one else
my children all three are uh
grown married uh great parents great
husbands and wives very functional
people
and i did not make every ball game i
didn't miss every ball game
but i didn't make every ball game i
didn't make every time they were a
cheerleader
i didn't make every time whatever that
was not how we
judged whether or not i was a good dad
yeah
uh i wasn't emotionally absent i wasn't
spiritually absent
but also i wasn't financially absent uh
we were building this business when
those kids were little and we were
trying to recover from a bankruptcy when
those kids were little
so i worked like a freaking maniac but
when i'm home i'm home
right dragging them around behind the
boat on tube
or you know we'd hit the lake in the
afternoons or whatever but
and uh even when you know they were in
the first book tour when i went out i
was gone six weeks
on the financial piece book tour um
with the promise of disney on the other
end when i get home
if you guys don't drive your mother to
an insane asylum while i'm gone
and so because we have to get her out of
a rubber room we're not going to disney
right and so there's a price to be paid
kiddos yeah
for us to get to do things that we want
to do as a family today our family can
do anything it wants to do
i mean anything we want to do and we
paid a price to get to that
point if you were to interview my
children you would not
they would not tell you that they were
emotionally abandoned by their father
or that they were not nurtured by their
father but they will tell you that dad
worked
yeah a lot yeah and when he was at work
he was at work like you said be where
your feet are
and um and so i really don't have a
bunch of guilt or shame about that i uh
uh but i was i would you know i coached
daniel's hockey team so obviously i had
to be there a lot to do that
you know so i was very plugged into that
but this idea that you have to be there
every time they poop their diaper that's
just ridiculous
and it's just complete overkill there's
something too in our world and you hit
on this with the whole television thing
but whether it's your phone social media
whatever
it focus on quality over quantity so
let's say you're in a season of working
two jobs to get out of debt
then what you can do is when the hours
that you spend with your child really
be there put your phone down turn the tv
off really be present so maybe it's not
as many hours as you would like long
term
that's okay focus on quality over
quantity really be present i use this
example i'd rather have
two hours with my family on a saturday
where we're all engaged playing together
than eight hours where everyone's
staring at a screen yeah but the point
is
if i go six weeks on the road we pay
cash for a house
when i get back and we go to disney and
now we don't have a house payment
now what's that mean well that means i
get to start to make some different
choices if i want to right
and you know when i work now whenever my
god i want to work that's right
and if i want to get up and uh you know
not be at the office until
noon and take all the grand babies
donuts in the morning which might have
happened a time or two
you know i can go do that so you know
what the what the
freedom that you're working for gives
you is freedom that's a good point
and it gives you options and so you're
living like no one else so
later you can live and give like no one
else this is not a death sentence and
it's not a lifetime
yeah he's a baby yeah and he's not you
know he's gonna
you know you're not missing his entire
childhood i mean what do military
families do when the
if the dad in this case is deployed for
six months and is overseas yeah
is does a child come does a child become
dysfunctional because of that
no they don't so much of it too and i'll
speak from my experience as a mom but so
much of it is we get in our own head
about it
yeah i remember dave i remember the when
carter so carter's my oldest child when
he turned two years old
was on the day of the very first
business boutique one day event
kicking off business boutique book
pre-sale so you and i are in california
i'm backstage about to go on stage
and i'm facetiming with carter and of
course it's like everything in my heart
is pulling towards oh my gosh today's
birthday and i'm not there but i'm like
the reality is okay if you get out of
your head the reality is
he will not remember i had already spent
the day before i left with him doing all
kinds of fun things we had a party for
him that we could
he was fine he was hanging out with his
dad doing all getting
ice cream and whatever he doesn't know
he's two
he's not gonna remember that so so much
it's in our head he doesn't know it's
his birthday no he's too
he doesn't know anything it's in our
head and how we feel
exactly about that situation this year
we decided your birthday's thursday
you know i may just tell you that's your
day it's good for us for your birthday
to be thursday this year so this year
it's thursday yes
you got celebrated you yeah you turned
two
you're fine yeah so i think if we can
get out of our own head
then we'll realize hey it gives us a
little bit of freedom like let me go
chase this dream pay off this debt build
this wealth whatever the thing is
so that just like you said so that i
have that freedom to make even different
choices if i want to
so work your butt off and get out of
debt so you can do that it's worth it
and uh noah here's the good news a man
that
asks this question is not a man who's
going to emotionally abandon his
children
it's not going to your your father was
absent from you you're not going to be
absent
because you asked the question right and
you put the you put the pledge down
before yourself that you're going to
keep that
you're going to keep your word you're
going to be present so you're going to
be present
and um i'm just saying dude
it's a bigger d like you said it's
bigger deal to you than it is a kid yeah
uh and you know unless you make a big
deal out of it right and
you know whale and carry-on and wine and
all this stuff and yeah it just it does
and so we just sat down had very direct
calm conversations with the kiddos this
is what we're doing
and they didn't really get a vote um and
i don't like that i don't really care
you're three whether you like it or not
i'm not taking a vote this is not a
democracy it's a benevolent dictatorship
so you know it's this is i love you and
i'm gonna take care of you
you don't need to worry about it it's
good life is good and so yeah that
that's a thing and
and the other thing is it's temporary
yeah it doesn't last forever that's
right doesn't last forever doesn't last
forever
doesn't last forever it's just for a
little while